à compter du 18 avril beaucoup plus
d'enfants devront obligatoirement
s'asseoir dans un siège d'appoint
les nouvelles règles s'appliquent à tous
les enfants de moins de 9 ans qui mesure
moins de 145 cm ou quatre pieds neuf
pouces s'est basé sur bon nombre
d'études qui sont venus dire que les
enfants par exemple qui sont sortis trop
rapidement et dans le sillage du 3ème
siècle sièges d'appoint et qui ont un
impact
les enfants ont souvent des blessures
sérieuses plus importante que s'il était
resté dans le siège avec la ceinture
c'est justement la ceinture qui causent
les blessures plutôt que de protéger si
elle passe au mauvais endroit
si l'enfant n'a pas la grandeur voulu la
ceinture risque de faire quoi bein
risque de passer au niveau de son cou ou
encore même des fois non malheureusement
on peut voir ce que demandez-vous de la
règle et peut-être au niveau de
l'abdomen et loeb un conséquemment ça
peut vouloir dire des blessures
sérieuses au cou colonne vertébrale
organes internes il est d'ailleurs
recommandé de garder le siège d'appoint
peu importe l'âge pour tous les enfants
de moins de 145 cm autrement dit à 9 ans
plus de 97 % des enfants devraient
toujours avoir un siège d'appoint à 10
ans le trois quarts des enfants sont
toujours trop petit il faut attendre à
plus de 11 ans pour que la majorité
atteignent la taille sécuritaire il faut
vraiment que les jambes des jeux du soin
d replié plus tomber naturellement
effectivement et que qui soit son dos
soit bien appuyer la ceinture doit
vraiment pas assez là haut niveau et
ange des eaux du bassin et au niveau de
l'épaule
c'est vraiment au milieu d'épaulé sur la
clavicule alors faut vraiment que la
ceinture soit ces deux à ces deux
endroits là et pourquoi parce que c'est
aulas et ces endroits ne sont
des endroits plus solide entre
guillemets pour absorber les chocs en
cas d'impact à l'entrée en vigueur des
nouvelles règles les parents qui seront
prises en défaut s'expose à une amende
de 80 à 100 dollars est à trois points
d'inaptitude